un feu nourri interrompt le discours du
chef du haut conseil afghan pour la paix
des rafales synonyme d'un nouvel
attentat dans la capitale afghane
l'attak vient cette fois de viser une
cérémonie commémorant la mort d'une
personnalité issue de l'influente
minorité hazara rapidement cet attentat
est revendiquée par le groupe etat
islamique qui multiplie les attaques
contre les chiites depuis 2015 ce
nouveau bain de sang survient moins
d'une semaine après la signature de
l'accord de doha entre les états unis et
les talibans washington s'est engagé à
un retrait de toutes les forces
étrangères du pays au cours des 14
prochains mois en échange les insurgés
promettent de ne pas aider d'autres
groupes terroristes et de les empêcher
de se servir de l'afghanistan comme
d'une base pour menacer la sécurité des
états unis et de leurs alliés
de son côté le président américain a de
nouveau réaffirmé sa volonté de laisser
l'afghanistan prendre en charge sa
propre sécurité nous avons été présents
pendant 20 ans et nous avons protégé le
pays
mais nous ne voulons pas être là pour
les 20 prochaines années
ils vont devoir se protéger eux mêmes
vous savez cela aurait dû être fait il
ya longtemps mais on ne peut pas tenir
la main de quelqu'un pendant si
longtemps il faut que nous recommencions
à gérer notre pays c'est donc dans ce
contexte à nouveau explosif que doivent
se tenir de nouveaux pourparlers entre
le pouvoir de kaboul et les talibans le
10 mars prochain à oslo le président
afghan ashraf ghani a déjà indiqué qu'il
rejetait l'un des principaux points de
l'accord de doha la libération de
milliers de prisonniers talibans en
échange de plusieurs centaines de
membres des forces afghanes détenus par
les insurgés
[Musique]